well this is a long battle let's see
what happened there was an early morning
signal a clue one campaign was close to
collapse as candidates arrived to make
their pitches to the GMB Union one was
missing this may be a three-month
campaign but just two weeks in jest
Phillips is out the Labour Party will
need to select a candidate that can
unite all parts of our movement the
union movement the members their elected
representatives and I have to be honest
with myself as I said oh who is would be
throughout this campaign there at this
time that person isn't me some
supporters believe her decision was
unfortunate but inevitable she's
inspired tens of thousands of people to
join the Labor Party but ultimately as
just as said in with a characteristic
honesty she's not been able to build the
breadth of support right across the
labor movement that she needs in order
to be a successful leader of the Labour
Party at this time she may have had a
lot of support here in Parliament but
beyond this bubble Jess Phillips was
battling to remain relevant not a single
local labour party or union bacter and
she faced the prospect of her whole
campaign shuddering to a humiliating
halt the remaining four candidates are
now each attempting to Hoover up Jess
Phillips his supporters to win a place
in the third and final round contenders
need to clear one of two hurdles either
by securing five percent of local labour
parties all five percent of labour
affiliates largely trade unions so far
sakir stahma is the only candidate
through to the final round amongst his
backers two of the four big unions as
door and unison this afternoon another
of the big four unions announced they
are backing Lisa Nandi with a nod to the
bruising battle ahead to claim the
Labour throne the overwhelming majority
of GMB executive was to back
Lisa Mandy they felt that she was the
one with fresh ideas a real breath of
fresh air the one with innovation
dynamism that gets the size of the
challenges but he's confident that we
return to power Jess Phillips's
leadership journey is now at an end but
for Lisa Nandi today is a breakthrough
and could be the start of a serious
challenge for the top job Joe Pike Sky
News Westminster